>>Eric: Hi and I just want to say it's an
honor today to bring AXS Lab, to Google and
their featured project, Axis Map.
And it's really about taking this idea of
accessibility and going out into the world
and how to we make this more inclusionary
environment.
And with that I actually want to give a quick
introduction for each of our guests today.
First I'll actually introduce Jason.
He's the founder of AXS Lab.
He's also a director even before this project.
Some of his work has been featured at Sundance
and HBO and PBS.
He is the founder and the kind of president
of this initiative.
And Alice is our executive director.
She graduated from Stanford in Environmental
Engineering with a Masters and has been just
doing great ever since and really keeps this
ship afloat here.
And then, their newest member today, Kevin
Bluer, he been in web, mobile web development
for ten years.
Um, and it's just ah a serial entrepreneur
and we're luck to have him as a part of this
team.
So as a little bit of background, I was introduced
to these folks in early 2011 in New York City
as part of a technical incubator.
And what I've loved to and responded to immediately
to this team, is this is a team that's taking
data and maps and combining it with story
telling.
And that is an incredibly powerful combination.
And they're using this together to really
try to make a difference in the world.
So I'm honored to bring them here today so
you can hear their story, their journey and
see some of their initial results.
And I'm also to happy to note that they are
in part funded by Sundance and other groups
who are also Google and, the Google earth
outreach developer grant as well.
So with that, give them a round of applause
and we'll turn over
the mic.
[Applause]
>>Jason: Thanks Eric.
My name is Jason DeSilva.
I'm the creator of AXS Map.
>>Alice: And I'm Alice Cook the producer of
AXS Map.
>>Kevin: And I am Kevin Bluer, the lead developer
of of AXS Map.
>>Jason: So let's just jump right in.
So this may be a surprising statistic but
actually one out six people have a disability
of some kind.
I happen to be one of those people.
I have primary progressive multiple sclerosis.
I was diagnosed in 2005 and I saw over the
course of 7 years I've gone from walking just
fine to using a cane to a walker to a wheelchair
to a scooter where I am today.
And you know I'm a documentary filmmaker,
as Eric said.
I've been working as a documentary filmmaker
for 10 -15 years now.
I made films on PBS on HBO, I had a film with
Sundance, so it was natural for me, I decided
to take the camera and turn it on myself and
make a film.
The film is called 'When I Walk' it was picked
up by PBS.
It'll be broadcasting on PBS next year and
it really goes through and shows my whole
journey.
The, actually the making of AXS Map is in
the film, so that's the connection here.
So let's go ahead and show a preview of the
film.
[Film]
>>Female 1: I couldn't imagine my son being
a depressed person, because he has always
been up and about laughing and smiling.
He was just walking weird across the street,
walking, crossing the street at an angle.
>>Jason: We have a diagnosis, you have multiple
sclerosis.
>>Female 1: At least we can postpone him being
in a wheelchair and the doctor just looked
at us point blank and said 'No, he will be
in a wheelchair soon'.
>>Male 1: We will have problems that are consistent.
>>Male 2: Even normal people have patterns
that aren't quite as repeatable.
>>Jason: it was frustrating.
Multiple sclerosis was taking over my life.
I'm gonna do to do everything in my power
to make sure that doesn't happen.
[Music]
>>Female 1: When you think your life is bad
think of situations like this.
>>Male 3: Everything in your mind.
[Multiple voices]
[Man breathing]
>>Jason: Getting a tattoo is nothing compared
to MS.
It's just like child's play.
We all have different struggles, but they're
more similar than we think.
[Music]
>>Jason: So this is my neighborhood in the
east Village before I was diagnosed with MS
you can find me waking up, going for brunch
some place, I catch lunch or dinner at a restaurant
with a friend.
I'd go to a bar or a club at night, I believed
the whole world, the world was my oyster and
New York was my playground.
You know and then I got MS and then I started
slowly having trouble walking.
So as my walking faded my neighborhood faded
and then my community involvement faded as
well.
So during this time I was inspired with the
idea of AXS Map and that's that's what happened,
so what I'm going to do now is show you, I'm
just going jump right in, show you a little
animation all about AXS map.
[Film]
>>Jason: Hi!
My name is Jason and I use a scooter to get
around.
It's not so easy.
I have trouble going to stores, finding bathrooms
that are accessible and meeting up with friends.
[Phone ringing]
>>Jason: Of course I can call ahead but many
places say they're accessible, but really
they're not.
There has to be a better way.
So I had an idea.
What if everyone could share all the accessible
places they know?
And what if all this was put on one map?
And that map was available on the web and
mobile phones?
I call it AXS Map.
In the online and mobile app where anyone
can search for accessible places, or view
them on their entry ways or bathrooms.
AXS Map opens up a whole new world of choices
and I can instantly find all the accessible
places around.
Where to eat, shop, grab a coffee or get a
haircut.
Even if you're not in a wheelchair you're
invited to give ratings and contribute.
AXS map is powered by you.
The more you review, the better it gets.
For people with canes, walkers or wheelchairs,
even moms and dads with strollers.
AXS Map is your ticket to mobility freedom.
It's easy and free to use.
Help make this world a more inclusive one.
Join the movement today.
Check it out.
AXSMap.com
[Music]
>>Jason: Thanks now I'm going to pass it over
to Kevin Bluer who's the lead technologist
for the project.
>>Kevin: Thanks Jason.
Hi everyone, as mentioned my name's Kevin
Bluer the lead developer on AXS Map.
So I'm just going to go through a few things.
I'm going to start with a quick walk through
of what we've built so far.
And then I'm going to take a step back just
to show some of the design decisions we've
made, in kind of building the product, talk
briefly through the API and so on.
Then, jump to the kind of future, talk about
kind of some of the upcoming releases, and
some of the concepts we'd like to you know
put in, medium to long term.
Kay so this is the home screen of AXS Map
going to go from the top down, you can kind
of see the two, the two search boxes.
On the left, the venues, some of the examples
Jason mentioned, cafe restaurant bar, etc.
On the right you can put in the location,
so your zip, post code or street, whatever.
And then, the middle for now we've just got
the video which you saw was pretty nice it
kind of tells Jason's story pretty well, it
kind of frames what the application or the
platform is about.
We may change that over time, but you know
it's there right now, on the right we've got
just categories, so you can kind of jump right
into a specific place.
This is the search results screen, so after
you've done a search on the left you've just
got the stars, the other attributes which
we'll come on to in a moment.
The two ratings you saw, as you saw in the
animation are getting in, which is obviously
fundamental.
If you can't get into a place then you know
nothing else really matters.
Beneath that we've got restrooms, once you
are inside, you know if you need to know how
accessible the restrooms are, then that's
there.
There kind of two, what we found to be two
most important measures.
On the right hand side we've got Google map,
which is great that's very high level on Manhattan
right now, but obviously typically you'd zoom
in a lot lower than that.
This is a venue page, so again, the two measures
there and then we've got a bunch of other
attributes which I'll come on to in a moment.
In the top right we've actually got the Google
street view imbedded which is a great service
and I know Jason and Alice would use that
and still do use that before going out to
a venue.
So now it's imbedded right in the place.
And the actually graphic up there you can
just see, I've just zoomed in on a step.
So it's just as an example, it's a pretty
useful tool just determining that.
Below that we've got the aerial view and below
all that we've got the ratings from the individual
contributors, so you know any additional comments
and stuff, you know pretty straightforward.
This is adding a review, so again the same
measure as you saw in the animation there.
It's kind of nice, kind of big chunky icons
you know very visual, very easy just to click
the stars.
Now the attributes, we've got going from left
to right and these are just kind of ones you
light up, so if they're kind of binary, if
their applicable.
So you know we've the spaciousness of the
venue, kind of traversable inside the venue,
we've then got the quiet, so the volume inside
the venue, whether there's disabled parking,
whether they've got a disabled ramp, or sort
of a ramp for getting up, getting up stairs
if they have stairs.
We then have a second entryway as well, so
whether there's an entryway that's not visible,
you know, from the primary entryway.
And then on the far right where there's Braille,
so again if there's Braille on the menu, Braille
menu on the signs and so on.
And below that we've got comments, so just
you know if there's any sort of tips or quirks
about the venue, that are not covered in those
above, you know attributes, you can add additional
things there.
I was going to quickly show you a video the
guys have put together on how to rate, which
is kind of quirky and gives you a bit of insight,
a bit more detail on the rating system.
[Film]
[Music]
>>Jason: Hi my name is Jason.
I'm the founder of AXS Map.
Today we're going to give you some tips on
giving reviews.
So, let's hit the street.
>>Alice: Hi I'm AXS map scout Alice.
Today Jason's asked me to give a review.
I'm just about to stop here for a bite to
eat.
So let's take a look.
So as you can see this place is kind of amazing
for accessibility.
Huge entryway, totally flat, no lip here whatsoever
and no heavy door for anybody to open.
I'm going to give this place five stars.
So now that we're inside I'm going to check
a couple other features.
The first thing I'm going to check is, is
it spacious?
This is spacious is really spacious.
Tap here to vote yes for spacious.
The other thing I'm checking to see if it's
it really quiet.
It's a really great place, it's at the height
of brunch but it still the volume isn't too
loud.
So I'm going to tap quiet.
Now lets go check out the bathrooms.
In this place, like the entryway looks amazing.
The key is the door opens out.
It gives enough space for someone using a
wheelchair and an assistant to get inside.
Notice that it has a bar here and two bars,
key, having two bars.
The toilet is a decent height.
The sink is a little high, but I'm still giving
it five stars.
And that's it, that's my review.
So that was fun.
I also had lunch and the food here happens
to be amazing.
So let's check out another place and give
another review.
[Music]
>>Alice: Ok so I'm going to stop in this shop.
Looks like there's one step.
I'm going give it a two stars.
But first I'm going to check to see if they
have a portable ramp, if they have portable
ramp I'll give it four stars.
Let's go inside.
Ok so I just asked the shop owner and they
don't have a ramp, so I've gotta give it two
stars.
So Jason has another scout out giving reviews
today, let's check in with him.
>>Steve: Hi I'm AXS map scout Steve.
And I'm out giving reviews today.
So I'm at this Laundromat.
So you can see it's got two steps, so I'm
going to give that a one star rating.
So this place's got one step, so I'm going
to give a two, before I do I want to check
to see if it's got maybe a portable ramp,
or if it's got an alternative entrance.
Ok so they just told me there's an secondary
entrance around the back so let's go back
and check it out and see how good it is.
Ok, so you can see they've got an accessible
door right here, so it's not clear from the
outside, so I wouldn't this a five, so I'm
going to give this place a four star rating.
So this place has got one step, but I checked
inside but they've actually got a ramp, so
we're going to get it out and see what it
looks like.
Beautiful!
Great!
I'm going to give this place four stars.
Ok so I stopped at a hardware store and they
actually do have a ramp, but it's a bit steep,
so instead of four I'm going to give it a
three star.
>>Jason: So that was some examples of how
to give reviews.
Just to recap, that was a one, that was a
two, that was a three, the portable ramp was
four and that was a five.
Keep in mind there is no wrong answer.
And think like you're using a wheelchair or
a scooter.
And have fun!
[Music]
>>Kevin: Ok, so just continuing with some
of the screens we put together just to give
you that insight.
This is some screen shots from the mobile
apps we have.
As you can see it's kind of consistent with
the design and style that we put together
for the main web.
Bigger emphasis on kind of categories.
Also taking the [inaudible] obviously I haven't
got a map screen up there, but you know it
will hone in based on where you are of course.
Ah, and then just on the right hand side there,
you can see the rating of the venue again
consistent with the rest of the app.
Just taking a step back, designed like as
we saw started building it we had just sort
of bunch of goals in mind.
So they, you know, were kind of obvious emphasis
on simplicity and ease of use of course.
And broad appeal, you saw in animation you
know trying to cover a range of use cases
obviously.
In Jason's case being in a scooter right through
to anyone, being a Mum with a stroller and
it was kind of everything in between.
From the interface perspective you've seen
the kind of colors there.
We went for white on black, big fonts bigger
icons.
So just again a big emphasis on ease of use.
I actually worked with a few different designers
as well as including a fellow Googler, Rick
Farrell, so I want to say thanks to him for
some of his insights which were great.
and these are some actually screen shots,
or some wire frames we put together, some
mock ups, jury you know before we actually
started any building and we made these interactive.
Which was great for, Jason and I to actually
kind of play around and move around within
the app, obviously a pure simulation.
Did that for the main web too.
And then on the right hand side there you
can see the the kind of actual first mock
up we got put together for the mobile web
version.
Terms of API and data, on the back end we're
using Google places API which has been great.
As you saw as well obviously using Google
maps and street view, you know it's great,
really really good services and to be honest
we couldn't have built this without some of
those.
In terms of the data we'll kind of recapture
and augment on top.
It's been kind of interesting balance and
we've seen it as a journey, not a destination
in so much that we try to get the balance
between you know capturing the relevant information,
you know to make and to allow someone to determine
whether it is accessible but not over burdening
reviewers as well.
So you know asking someone to ok give me fifty
different attributes when you're adding a
review.
So we're trying to strike that balance and
we certainly welcome feedback on that.
And some points towards the end and how you
can give that feedback.
And finally in terms of our AP- We've built
an API as well.
Right now our apps consuming that API and
over time we intend to, well right now as
of right now open that up to anyone else who
wants to interesting in consuming the data
that we capture.
From a build perspective I'm not going to
go into any depth here at all, it's just for
those who are technical in the audience this
is a technology stack that we've used.
In terms of testing we've actually worked
through, obviously Jason and then other members
of the community to get feedback out of it
and again you know very much intend to do
that as we you know evolve the app.
And again just to reiterate throughout the
talk, the rest of the talk about getting feedback
from yourselves would be fantastic.
So in terms of upcoming release it's kind
of live today, which is literally, like today
is almost the launch of the first iteration,
beyond that you know very soon we've got a
new interaction coming which is going to have
photo uploads to allow people to take photos
of you know key things in and around the venues.
So be that outside the doorway or the restrooms,
which again to add that kind of visual layer
on top which would be great.
And richer filters as well so you can actually
do a search for something like show me the
available you know restaurants in my area
that have Braille menus for example.
We got an android app coming really really
soon too.
And then obviously incremental sort of tweaks
and fixes.
And then bigger picture, just an insight into
some of the sort of more conceptual things
we'd like to do, going from left to right,
getting gamification is something we'd been
exploring, so adding kind of incentivization
mechanics and getting mechanics on top to
actually encourage people to add reviews.
The middle visualization as well, so you know
as we build this data set, actually adding
visualization layers on top so you can answer
kind of questions and there's one up in there.
How accessible is my city?
Or that could be how accessible is my neighborhood
or my state or whatever.
So some interesting things we could certainly
start exploring there.
And on the far right we've got augmented reality,
so just different interfaces on top of the
data sets.
We've just got a quick mock up which I'll
show you now, which is pretty nice about how
this could work.
>>Jason: Just just to give some personal context
is really I'm having trouble with my hands
right now it would be really great to be able
to hold up my phone to just see all the places
around me that are accessible.
>>Kevin: yeah that's cool stuff and as we
were talking with Eric about the Google glasses
another cool thing would be maybe add in on
down the line.
Ah so with that I'm going to hand over to
Alice Cook who is the producer for AXS Maps
to talk a bit about the future.
>>Alice: Thanks.
So when I'm not out scouting for Jason I'm
producing AXS Map, and first, so yeah and
I'm going to cover the future in terms of
how we're going to engage community and how
we're really going to get data into the app.
So Jason founded a non-profit three years
ago called AXS Lab.
Our mission is to supercharge the disability
movement, disability rights movement, to engage
audiences, to playfully explore the disability
experience, story is important to us as Eric
said in the beginning and kind of the mission
behind the mission is to make the world a
more compassionate, inclusive and enriching
place.
So the first two big initiatives of AXS Lab
are the, Jason's film "When I Walk" and then,
of course, AXS Map. so one of the ways we
think we're fulfilling our mission with AXS
Map is is trying to give disab- a fresh identity
for disability.
So everyone's familiar with this symbol on
the left is the international symbol for wheelchair
accessibility, it references the hospital
blue, sort of the medical model of the disability
identity and so we want for AXS Map we wanted
a new identity that reflected the crowd source,
the empowered community of disability.
So the idea was to use you know a strong yellow
and give it a sportier, more youthful, just
a fresher identity for disability.
So these are our funders.
We're so proud to be working with such a prestigious
group of funders.
Google Earth as Eric mentioned, helped fund
us, and that grant was administered by the
Tides Foundation.
Our largest supporters are actually a prestigious
foundation in New York called the Nathan Cummings
Foundation.
They're really movers and shakers in the philanthropy
world.
They called AXS Map their Jeremy Lin of philanthropic
endeavors.
So we are really proud to be working with
them.
Fledgling Fund is another, is behind us, and
of course, Finance and PBS are behind the
film "When I walk."
so the future of AXS Map, how we are going
to engage communities.
the first thing is really populating the database.
Because it's not going to be a useful tool
until we get a lot of data in.
And that way we're going to be doing that
is by holding community mapping days.
So I'll tell you a little bit about that.
We're also going to be encourage accessibility.
We want to encourage business owners to become
accessible if their not already accessible.
And then the last one, we think that the thing
that's really going to coalesce this as a
movement is really about sharing stories and
gathering stories from the community.
So for business owners we're going to offering
window stickers.
This is like our first way of engaging business
owners.
And we think this is really, going to be a
fun way for business owners to distinguish
themselves.
They can put this in the window to show any
wheelchair users passing by that they are
accessible.
Maybe that their main entryway isn't but they
have an alternative entrance.
The other really great thing is that is a
form of market distinction.
So they can show that they're socially responsible
and this is something they care about.
so our mapping days, our first mapping day
was actually last year, May 12, 2011. and
that went well, but we were just using clipboards
and going out across Brooklyn.
So what happens on a mapping day we bring
together a group of volunteers, they meet
in one place, we form teams and then they
fan out across a neighborhood, exploring the
neighborhood on foot and inputting reviews
on accessibility.
And one of the really fun things we're doing
on our mapping days is letting participants
test drive a scooter.
And I think able body participants test drive
a scooter just to experience what it's like
to navigate the world using a scooter.
So the vision is, in the next year we would
have fif- we're working to set up partnerships
with big non- national non-profits to set
up mapping days so we'd have- This is a mock
up that would be a page on the site to show
there'd be 50 mapping days all across the
country and you could look here to find a
mapping day near you to get engaged.
The other thing we think is important is this
is that, this is a grassroots sort of movement
and that individuals can lead their own mapping
days.
And actually we've already had some people
reaching out to us who want to host their
own mapping day.
Which is really exciting, and actually it
was just two weeks ago a student from upstate
New York named Matthew reached out to us and
said that he wanted to lead a mapping day,
we had a chance to video chat with him, just
a few days ago and so we're going to share
that video chat with you with Matthew.
>>Matthew: [computer voice] Hi my name is
Matthew Ballow; I'm almost 18 years old.
I am from Clarence, New York which is a town
outside of Buffalo.
I go to school at Clarence Senior High.
I like to read and watch movies.
I also like to play computer games and board
games.
I also like to go to the mall near my house,
bowling at my local bowling alley and out
to different restaurants.
AXS Map could give me more freedom, because
it would help me know in advance what places
in my community I would be able to go.
Where I can drive myself around.
It is important to me to be independent.
I need a lot of help with my daily tasks but
one thing I can do all by myself is drive
and operate my wheelchair.
I think AXS Map will help both people in wheelchairs
and people who are with people who are in
wheelchairs.
Personally it is frustrating when I cannot
get around some place for both me and whoever
is with me.
I would like to lead a mapping day.
I think it will be fun to travel around my
community and see where I can go.
I also would like to do this because it will
help other people in my community who are
in a wheelchairs and face the same challenges
I do when they want to go out.
Nice to meet you.
>>Alice: So that's Matthew and we're so excited
that he reached out to us and we think it's
a great example of how individuals can step
up and lead up mapping days.
And we also think his story is a great story
for showing why accessibility matters.
When you have such great challenges and for
Matthew the one thing he can really do is
drive and operate his wheelchair, it means
a lot when he can he can get in a business
or a restaurant.
So on that note, we're actually having a mapping
day this Saturday in San Francisco and we're
inviting Googlers to attend.
It's near Soma at the 155 Ninth Street.
The time 12:15 you can RSVP to Jason if you're
interested.
Really thank you to Eric for coordinating
this and a thank you to our other supporters,
the Google, Google Earth team, Tanya Birch
and Raleigh Seamster have been really supportive
of the project and I think we could open it
up to questions.
Yeah.
[Clapping]
>>Alice: Thank you.